so today I was talking to my therapist
when she said you need friends but I
have been trying to get friends oh oh
yeah I remember that how's that going
and look I do have friends okay they're
called books or cats and I kind of think
like being alone is healthy it's okay
I'm just a solitary person but now that
my therapist is basically confirmed
you're a loser
I'm starting to re-evaluate my social
life because your social life isn't just
about hanging out and having fun it's
apparently an emotional support system
and there's a life outside of work
are you serious and I don't know I just
feel like it's harder to maintain
friendships when you're an adult you
know especially because we live in this
digital age now where we can call text
Skype who needs face-to-face interaction
when you have social media leading a
very isolated life can lead to
depression and very intense feelings of
loneliness I would argue that I'm very
happy but you're the one with the degree
in psychology so wish me luck Internet
will I go out into the real world try to
find friends and have social
interactions and be vulnerable and open
to connect to people on a real emotional
level scary and I encourage you to
reevaluate your social standings and see
if you have a support system of people
that you love and trust and if not maybe
we will bump into each other on the
street see you next Monday stay awesome
Gotham